تعود القوات الحكوميه العراقيه الى سيرتها
الاولى في الانبار بعد توقف قصير ترافق مع
الانتخابات الاخيره تشن حمله عسكريه واسعه
النطاق والعنف على الفلوجه والسقلات
المدينتين من عده محاور ومن الجو والبر
بالتزامن مع اغلاق معبر المفتول المنفذ
الوحيد الذي يربط الفلوجه بالقلايه وبقيه
المدن العراقيه
الاخرى تعزل المدينه اذا لكن ذلك وفقا
للمصادر لم يمنح القوات الحكوميه اسباب
النصر المبتغى فقد منيت بخسائر فادحه في
الارواح كما وجهت بمقاومه وصفت بشرسه من
مسلحي العشائر وبحسب الروايه الحكوميه فان
الحمله تستهدف تطهير المنطقه من مسلحي
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام وان
ثمه تقدما على الارض تحرزه هذه القوات
لتحقيق هدفها ياتي هذا في سياق حمله بدات
نهايه العام الماضي على محافظه الانبار
كبرى المحافظات العراقيه قامت خلالها
القوات الحكوميه بقصف مدن المحافظه
وبلدتها تحت شعار القضاء على ما تسميه
الارهاب وبينما اعتبرت قوى عشائريه
وسياسيه ما يحدث تصفيه مذهبيه تحت شعارات
سياسيه مضلله قال تقرير للمفوضيه العليا
لشؤون اللاجئين ان الهجمات الحكوميه هناك
خلفت كار
انسانيه هي الاسوا في البلاد منذ 2008
بنزوح اكثر من 300 الف مواطن من الانبار
وسط ظروف انسانيه بالغه التعقيد
والصعوبه على ان سياسيين معارضين للمالك
يقولون ان حملته تلك قدر ما تعكس فشلا
ذريعا فانها تعكس انتهازيه سياسيه تسعى
لتعظيم مكاسب الرجل السياسيه بالدرجه
الاولى فقص الانبار كان برايهم حمله
انتخابيه قام بها الرجل بالطائرات
والدبابات لحصد الاصوات في صناديق
الاقتراع ويلفت هؤلاء الى التصعيد العسكري
غير المسبوق قبيل اجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه الاخيره وهو ما ترجم مكاسب
سياسيه للرجل بفوز كتلته بالعدد الاكبر من
الاصوات ويقول هؤلاء ان استئناف القصف على
الفلوجه وجوارها ياتي في السياق نفسه لدفع
ترشيحه لولايه ثالثه من قوى المكون
الشيعي الى التراجع عن موقفهم هذا
والانضواء تحت رايه حكومته
وحروبها